Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zur Ligatour. Heute geht es wieder um die 2. Liga. Ihr könnt euch freuen auf eine tolle Sendung moderiert wieder von Eva. Warum hört ihr mich? Vielleicht habt ihr es schon eine Ahnung. Unsere Kontoverbindung wird sich ändern. Ist nicht unsere Entscheidung, ist ein bisschen tricky für uns, denn jetzt müssen sich alle Daueraufträge von euch auch ändern, damit der Rasenfunk weiter Paywall-Werbe und Sponsoren frei bleiben kann. Das Ganze wird relativ bald geschehen. Wir werden voraussichtlich morgen am 19. März die neue Kontoverbindung erhalten und dann sagen wir auch über alle Kanäle, die wir haben, euch SupporterInnen Bescheid. Was ihr aber jetzt schon tun könnt, um auch wirklich mitzubekommen, auf welches Konto ihr dann euren Dauerauftrag bitte in Zukunft umstellt, ist euch als SupporterInnen zu registrieren. Einfach auf rasenfunk.de gehen und dann im Menü rechts oben eine Registrierung abschließen. Das bedeutet einfach nur, dass wir eure E-Mail-Adresse bekommen. Keine Angst, wir werden euch nicht zuspämmen. Da bekommt man im Schnitt so ein bis zweimal pro Jahr eine E-Mail. Und aber auf jeden Fall auch morgen oder die Tage dann, wenn wir die neue E-Bahn haben, bekommt er diese Informationen. Wir hoffen, dass dieser Umschwung nicht zu sehr den Rasenfunk schadet, denn da gehen immer ein paar SupporterInnen verloren. Aber deswegen ja diese Aufsager. Bitte registriert euch als SupporterInnen und jetzt geht es los mit der Sendung. Viel Spaß euch!
Das hast du schön gesagt, aber was ja auch zur Geschichte dazu gehört. Van Wonderen war, glaube ich, da gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt drei Monate da. Da hat er selber seinen Rücktritt angeboten im Dezember, ich glaube, vorm Paderborn-Spiel, wenn ich das so richtig gehört habe. Das hat man dann ja sehr wild gewonnen am Ende des Tages. Es stand wohl damals auch schon Funkel als Nachfolger bereit. Natürlich, der ewige Friedhelm Funkel wäre er sonst.
Man kommt total schnell vom Krefelder Tennisplatz nach Gelsenkirchen. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem für Friedhelm. Das ist perfekt.
Das ist wirklich– Halle sind Liga ist so ein Meme. Das ist wirklich unfassbar. Aber es stand wohl eben schon bereit. Schalke wollte es damals nicht akzeptieren. Es gab dann damals eben auch einen sehr guten Dezember, möchte ich fast sagen. Also mit Siegen gegen Paderborn, gegen Elvesberg und entschieden gegen Düsseldorf. Und generell finde ich schon, dass man– also rein ergebnistechnisch– man gewinnt meistens die Spiele gegen die Konkurrenz unten drin, was ja erstmal wichtig ist, wenn du dich aus diesem Abstiegskampf verabschieden willst. Du bist jetzt gerade in diesem, ich möchte es freundlich sagen, Grau- und Maus-Alltag angekommen, was ja per se trotzdem trotz allem, was Schalke natürlich jetzt auch durchgemacht hat, ja jetzt auch per se nicht so schlecht ist. Aber ich lese wirklich, du brauchst ja wirklich nur KSVW und googeln und es erscheint innerhalb von zwei Minuten acht Artikel darüber, so hier neun Punkte spielen, also beziehungsweise die nächsten drei Partien gegen, du hast es angesprochen, Viert und Ulm und dann eben gegen Regensburg, da sollen neun Punkte her. Also ich frage mich halt da so ein bisschen, solche Gerüchte, die werden ja auch von irgend wem in die, also vereinsnah in die Welt gesetzt, dass dieses, dieser Rücktritt oder Gerücht oder die Tatsache auf einmal Ende Januar, Anfang Februar gestreut wurde, das hat ja per se meistens leider auch einfach Gründe, ich glaube dafür sind wir alle zu lange im Fußball unterwegs. Warum, denkst du, macht man sich denn vereinseitig, also da auch diesen Kasten irgendwie wieder auf, dieses Thema wieder auf?
Also ich würde gerne einmal vorwegstellen, ich fand es menschlich groß von von Wunderern, dass er quasi direkt gesagt hat, ja, ich habe tatsächlich den Rücktritt angeboten, also als diese ganze Nummer aufgekommen ist, dass er da nicht irgendwie drum herum gedruckst hat, sondern gesagt hat, ja, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, ich zünde hier nicht, wie ich es mir in den ersten Wochen gewünscht habe und dann hat die Mannschaft ein Stück weit für mich geantwortet und jetzt glaube ich daran, dass ich eben seinen vielbeschworenen Prozess hier weiterführen kann. Ich glaube, Schalke ist halt ein großer Verein mit vielen Strömungen und entsprechend viele Leute wollen da mitreden. Entsprechend lancieren dann halt die eine oder anderen Parteien Geschichten, sei es jetzt Raoul, wo ich auch dann Manga, beziehungsweise ich weiß nicht, ob es Manga war am Ende tatsächlich, aber irgendjemand hat ja dann auch bestätigt, ja, man sei nach Madrid gereist und habe mit Raoul gesprochen, wo ich mir denke, du hast einen Trainer zu Hause sitzen, warum machst du dir die Baustelle auf? Also du fliegst ja nicht nur nach Madrid und sprichst mit Raoul über die spanische Sonne, sondern willst ja irgendwie auch über Schalke gehen und über ihn als Trainer und in so einer Situation, das stärken natürlich Van Wonderen Rücken auch nicht. Ich glaube, Van Wonderen ist schon auch am hadern, ich glaube, er hat sich das alles nicht so verzweckt vorgestellt, aber ich glaube auch, er ist im positiven Sinne dann auch bei sich und denkt, na ja, ich kann nur das beeinflussen, was ich beeinflussen kann und was passiert, passiert. Ich glaube, Van Wonderen wäre nicht so ein Typ, der sollte jetzt gehen müssen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer gegen den Verein schießt, was ja da Geraz vor einigen Monaten gemacht hat, in mehreren belgischen Zeitungen. Also sehr aktiv nach vorne gegangen ist und eine kleine, private Schmutzkampagne gegen den Verein gefahren hat. Weil du einfach gesehen hast, der Typ hat sich so auf den Schlips getreten, gefühlt mit der ganzen Manga-Geschichte und so. Der hat sich da irgendwie eine Karrieremöglichkeit mit Schalke verbaut gesehen gehabt. Und so schätze ich Van Wonderen nicht ein. Aber ja, die Frage, wer jetzt diese ganze Unruhe streut, kann ich dir so klar nicht beantworten. Weil auf der einen Seite stellt sich gerade Jürgen Mölder öffentlich vor Van Wonderen, Tilmann, der jetzt in letzter Zeit sich ein bisschen weniger zum Sportlichen geäußert hat. Hat aber auch zumindest nicht rumgedruckt, sondern hat gesagt, Kees Van Wonderen ist unser Trainer. Was natürlich bei Schalke auch immer reinspielt, sind die großen Sponsoren, wo wir sicherlich gleich auch noch mal zu sprechen kommen. Und die haben natürlich auch ihre ganz eigenen Visionen und Ideen für den Verein. Und gerade Personen mit Geld denken auch, dass sie dann direkt Einfluss haben qua ihres Kontostandes. Und gerade bei Schalke gibt es eben ausreichend Kanäle, wo Leute mal dem einen oder anderen Funktionär was rein, so fliehen, und der wiederum guten Draht zu verschiedenen Boulevard-Zeitungen hat, die natürlich auch ihre Seiten füllen müssen und die nehmen das dann dankend an. Aber ja, unterm Strich ist es im Moment eine Gemengelage, wo man nicht weiß, wer steht noch hinter wem, wer ist mit wem noch grün, wer wird überhaupt im Sommer noch da sein. Ich meine, Matthias Tillmann ist ja auch jetzt in den vergangenen Wochen wieder so ein bisschen ins Wackeln geraten, auch unter anderem, weil die Genossenschaft, über die wir sicherlich gleich sprechen, nicht so den raketenmäßigen Start hingelegt hat, er da kommunikativ ordentlich zurückrudern musste. Wenn die ganze Geschichte mit Ben Wanga jetzt im Sommer wirklich irgendwie auseinandergehen sollte, dann wird Tillmann auch sehr viel weniger Kredit haben, wobei er aber natürlich immer noch mit seinem alten Buddy, Axel Hefals, Aufsichtsratvorsitzenden ein sehr gutes Schutzschild hat. Also, ja, es ist dieses Meme mit den roten Linien. Es ist ein einziges Schlachtfeld auf Schalke. Und das ist halt auf der einen Seite Unterhaltung pur, aber auf der anderen Seite auch wirklich nicht gut für den Blutdruck, wenn man wirklich was an dem Verein gefunden hat.
Ja, dann lass uns doch tatsächlich fast schon einmal auf die Genossenschaft gucken. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das viele mitbekommen haben, dass es seit dem 22. Januar ausschließlich Mitgliedern des Vereins sowie, glaube ich, juristischen Personen– heißt es richtig– möglich, Anteile an der Aufschalke-EG zu zeichnen. Also, das ist zum Beispiel auch der große Unterschied zur Genossenschaft bei St. Pauli. Da ist es ja auch außerhalb von dem Mitgliedsstamm eben möglich, hat sicherlich auch was mit der hohen Anzahl von Mitgliedern zu tun, die der Verein hat. Und es ist eben so, bisher wurden insgesamt 22.842 Anteile seit dem 26. Januar gezeichnet und insgesamt sind 190.400, also angelegt an das Gründungsdatum 1904, in der ersten Phase des Projekts verfügbar und es funktioniert eben so, dass die Schalker verkaufen quasi eben diese Genossenschaftsanteile für 250 Euro pro Stück, zuzüglich so einer Registrierungsgebühr von 75 Euro und dann soll eben das eingenommene Geld dafür genutzt werden, Stadionanteile zurückzukaufen, die eben bei Dritten liegen und eben auch so einen eigenen Kapital einfach aufzubauen. Also ich glaube…
Wobei ich dich da an einer Stelle kurz korrigieren würde, also man kauft Stadionanteile vom Verein zurück, also die IG kauft Anteile vom Verein, was eigentlich bedeutet, die Mitglieder kaufen sich selbst ihre Anteile ab, weil dadurch, dass der Verein ja quasi Besitzer des Stadions ist und der Verein Mitglieder geführt ist, sind die Mitglieder ja schon im Besitz des Stadions. Also es ist… Man verkauft eigentlich nur Luft, heiße Luft und Folklore, aber wo, wenn nicht auf Schalke?
Ja, und natürlich eben auch, ich glaube schon, dass man am Ende dann schon weiß, Folklore und halt die Sicherheit, dass der Verein vielleicht auch existiert bleibt. Also muss man ja auch einfach ganz krass zu sagen. Also ich meine, ich glaube, die Wichtigkeit dieses Projekts wäre nochmal anders, wenn man jetzt doch irgendwie um die 3. Liga noch hätte fürchten müssen, sage ich mal so. Es ist natürlich, wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, waren alleine mit Abschluss, also Jahresabschluss quasi 2023, musste man irgendwie 16 Millionen Zins- und Tilgungen zahlen. Das ist natürlich sehr, sehr viel Geld. Vor allem für halt einen Zweitligisten. Das ist einfach so. Wir haben es eben einmal schon im Vorbericht gesagt, die letzten Zahlen sind von Mitte Februar, glaube ich. Man wollte das, glaube ich, immer nach außen kommunizieren zu den Heimspielen.
Na ja, Tillmann hat gesagt, er möchte es nicht gezwungenermaßen bei jedem Heimspiel. Er hat formuliert, sie möchten es immer im Vorlauf der Heimspiele verkünden, wenn es was zu verkünden gibt. Und was für mich bedeutet, wenn man seit einem Monat nichts mehr bei Heimspielen verkündet hat, wird sich an dem aktuellen Stand von 6,2 Millionen generierten Euro nicht so viel getan haben, weil davor hat man halt in zwei Wochen erst einmal die 3 Millionen, die 5 Millionen, jetzt die 6,2 Millionen kommuniziert. Und jetzt ist halt seit vier Wochen, ist man so ein bisschen in der Schwebe. Es wurde ja kommuniziert, dass man bis zum 19.04., also auch da angelehnt an 1904, ans Gündungsjahr, bis dahin wollte man minimum 10 Millionen generieren. Aber auch, weil du jetzt von die 16 Millionen Tilgungslast die jährlich anfällt, die man auf jeden Fall quasi für die verschiedenen Darlehen und so weiter und so fort zahlen muss, dass die einfach weiterlaufen, dass der Verein auch weiter existieren bleibt, damit eben Spielergehälter, Mitarbeitergehälter und so weiter überhaupt gezahlt werden können. Selbst wenn du die 10 Millionen jetzt einnimmst bis zum 19.04., das ist ja eine einmalige Einnahme zunächst einmal, heißt, du hast nicht mal die Tilgungssumme eines Jahres dann eingenommen. Also das ist schon Wahnsinn, wenn man sich das überlegt, dass also diese ganze Million von Euro, die jetzt generiert werden, per se erstmal für andere eingenommen werden oder generell auch, dass der FC Schalke 04 jedes Jahr erstmal so plus minus 15 Millionen irgendwo her generieren muss, um das Banken und anderen Gläubige dann zahlen zu können, damit die weiter sagen können, alles klar, wir bedienen weiter eure Darlehenkredite ETC. Also das ist schon wirklich bemerkenswert, wie dünn sozusagen die Kasse oder wie leer die Kassen auf Schalke sind und wie pfiffig dann eben durchaus clevere Köpfchen, studierte Betriebswirtschaftler, wie Tillmann da dann werden, wie kreativ, um irgendwie neues Geld zu generieren. Weil klar, ich habe es schon gesagt, auf Schalke kannst du den Leuten wahrscheinlich auch Luft verkaufen. Jede Sonderedition, die du rausschmeißt, ist innerhalb von Minuten, von Stunden ausverkauft. Aber das kannst du ja auch nicht nonstop machen. Und selbst, wenn du irgendwie ein limitiertes Trikot raushaust, da generierst du ja auch nicht 10 Millionen mit. Weil so limitiert kann es ja dann nicht sein, wenn man damit irgendwie 10 Millionen generiert. Also ich finde diese Genossenschaftsidee grundsätzlich gut, dass man sagt, wir schweißen diese Genossenschaft von Schalke-Fans noch mehr zusammen, indem wir dem Ganzen auch die Namengenossenschaft geben. Und wir geben euch noch eine Möglichkeit von Mitspracherecht. Weil, wenn du Mitglied in der Genossenschaft bist, hast du ja auch eine Stimme in der Hauptversammlung der Genossenschaft. Wobei da auch die Frage ist, was wird am Ende in so einer Hauptversammlung besprochen? Also was mich zum Beispiel interessieren würde, aktuell oder in der aktuellen Saison hat der FC Schalke 04 ja die Arena vermietet gehabt an Schachtier Donitz, damit die im Exil ihre Champions League-Spiele austragen können. Wenn die Genossenschaft jetzt genügend Anteile zurückkauft, quasi vom Stammverein, und damit dann Mitsprache recht hat an der Nutzung des Stadions, was ist, wenn sich dann so eine Gruppe formiert und sagt, wir stimmen jetzt aber in der Hauptversammlung dagegen, dass Schachtier die Arena nutzt oder dass die Arena nicht mehr für Konzerte genutzt wird? Ich meine, es gibt ja allerlei Sachen, die die Leute irgendwie aufstößen können. Das wäre dann wiederum kontraproduktiv, weil allein die Vermietung der Arena an Schachtier Donetsk hat in dieser Saison, glaube ich, 2 Millionen reingespült. Und da ist, glaube ich, nicht mal das Catering, was an den Spieltagen über das Schalke-eigene Catering rausgegeben wurde. Deren Einnahmen sind dann noch nicht mal eingerechnet. Also ja, es ist cool, dass Schalke noch mal eine Möglichkeit der Mitsprache damit schafft. Aber man macht sich natürlich auch ein bisschen Baustellen damit auf, weil die Arena ist halt das Prunkstück und ist die Kronjuwele des Vereins. Ich meine, deswegen hat der Verein ja diese ganzen Schulden und das negative Eigenkapital, weil man die Arena immer noch abbezahlt und immer noch quasi den Zins und den Zinseszins des Stadionbaus Anfang der 2000 abbezahlt. Aber genauso lebenserhaltend ist sie eben allein als Event-Location, sei es Biathlon oder Konzerte und so weiter. Also da komplett so einer großen, anonymen Masse, in Anführungszeichen, da die Mitsprache zu geben, macht mich auch so ein bisschen kribbelig, hibbelig, weil man eben nicht weiß, was für komische Allienzen sich dann vielleicht für so eine Hauptversammlung zusammensetzen.
Zwei Nahfragen dazu. Erstens, wie bewertest du denn, dass per se erst mal nur Mitglieder dadurch angesprochen werden? Also dass man das wirklich darauf fokussiert?
Das finde ich erstmal grundsätzlich gut, weil Schalke das ja auch immer vor sich hin trägt, dass man Mitglied, Mitgliedergeführter Verein ist, dass die Mitglieder wirklich nur was zu sagen haben, dass eine Schalke-Mitgliedschaft etwas bedeutet. Da finde ich es gut, dass man sagt, du solltest schon Mitglied sein, wenn du hier auch noch über das Stadium mitbestimmen möchtest. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass Unternehmen ausgeschlossen sind, also juristische Personen. Und da ist halt für mich die Krux, weil wenn man sich anschaut mit Hagedorn und Tönnies, der immer noch mit seiner Marke Böcklunder unter den Top 5 Sponsoren auf Schalkes, haben zwei Partner von Schalke öffentlich der Genossenschaftsidee in der Absage geteilt. Schalke wirbt ja ganz offensiv, damit das Unternehmen reinkommt und eben nicht nur einen Anteil, wie vielleicht ich, für 250 Euro zeichnet einfach, um dann zu sagen, hey, ich bin Stadion-Teilhaber, obwohl man das eigentlich schon vorher war, sondern man hat dann mannigfaltige Möglichkeiten, gib mal direkt 50.000 Euro oder mehr. Aber da muss man halt auch sagen, bietet Schalke den Unternehmen eigentlich auch nicht so viele Möglichkeiten. Also ich hatte mir mal durchgeguckt, was kriegt man so, wenn man Summe X bekommt. Und das fängt dann halt an bei einem gerahmten Schalke-Trick, wo ich mir denke, gut, wenn du Sponsor bist, kriegst du das wahrscheinlich sowieso jedes Jahr. Dann geht es über ein Stadionnachbau. Irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht aus einem 3D-Drucker oder wie auch immer, ist ja auch bummsegal, aber da denke ich mir auch so, ja toll, das stellt sich der Vorstandsvorsitzende auf den Schreibtisch, aber zahlt er dafür wirklich 10.000 Euro an Anteilen. Und dann soll es ein Schalker Business Network geben, wo ich mich aber auch frage, da muss es ja eine gewisse Anzahl von Unternehmen erst mal geben, die sagen, jo, da schließen wir uns zusammen, damit es für die nächste juristische Person, das nächste Unternehmen überhaupt attraktiv ist. Also wenn da nur drei Leute oder drei Unternehmen in diesem Netzwerk sind, und die sind vielleicht sogar alle aus Gelsenkirchen, oder sind eh alle schon Logenbesitzer auf Schalke, oder treffen sich ohnehin schon jeden Samstag im blauen Salon, was ist dann der Zweck des Business-Metzwerkes? Also das ist ja kein Mehrwert dann für ein Unternehmen. Und ich glaube, das haben eben die Unternehmen Hagedorn und Tönnies auch so empfunden, dass der Mehrwert einer Investition nicht da ist. Und gerade solche Personen kriegst du dann halt im letzten Instanz nicht mehr mit Vollklohe, wenn es dann halt nicht mehr um 250 Euro, sondern vielleicht auch um 250.000 oder 25.000 Euro, je nachdem, geht. Weil solche Personen sind schon mit ihren eigenen Logen vertreten, sind schon überall sichtbar in und um die Arena. Also die haben auch nichts davon, dass an diesem Förderturm, der da jetzt gebaut werden soll im Stadionumfeld, eine Plakette von denen dran ist. Also ich glaube, klar, das sind Personen, die gerne ihr Ego gestreichelt bekommen, aber wie gesagt, der Name oder der Name ihres Unternehmens ist schon viel größer und viel sichtbarer in der Arena zu sehen. Die brauchen das nicht, so eine Plakette.
Ja, aber das ist nämlich das Ding, also das kann auch sein, ich fand da die Infos zu tatsächlich auch sehr, sehr schwameg, die man so nachlesen konnte. Weil ich habe, wenn ich das nämlich auch richtig nachgelesen habe, ist, dass die ja auch in irgendeiner Weise schon irgendwie Mitglied, also in Anführungszeichen Mitglied des Vereins sein müssen. Und das ist natürlich, also wenn du neue, vielleicht auch eben was du eben sagst, neue Unternehmen auch aus der Region ansprechen willst, die vielleicht vorher noch nicht im Sponsoring und die dann ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, eine Bande kriegen, eine, weiß ich nicht, Werbung auf einer Anzeigetafel, ein Trikotsponsor, also die 80.000 Möglichkeiten, die es ja vom Makro bis Großsponsorin gibt, haben. Also wie denkst du, dass du denen da die Sichtbarkeit gibst? Also glaubt man wirklich, dass das dann irgendwie so eine Sache wird, dass man restliche Mitglieder zusammenschweißt da und da eben die Markensichtbarkeit erhöht und so? Also das geht dann natürlich auch tief ins Sponsoring rein, beziehungsweise in das Verständnis von Genossenschaft. Aber ich glaube, weil es ist ja auch egal per se, wie hoch dieser Anteilserwerb ist, aber sie kriegen ja, glaube ich, trotzdem nur eine Stimme in dieser Genossenschaft.
Genau, und das ist ja auch prinzipiell sehr gut, weil du eben dadurch nicht sozusagen so ein Oligarchentum durch die Hintertür ermöglicht, dass eben jetzt ein Großsponsor sagt, ich bin bisher ein Großsponsor, aber jetzt putter ich mal ein paar Hunderttausend in die Genossenschaft und kaufe mich quasi dadurch in den Verein ein. Das ist gut gelöst. Aber ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube, die Personen, Unternehmen, die eh schon im Umfeld von Schalke tätig sind, sehen eben nicht den Sinn darin, jetzt noch in der Genossenschaft groß zu investieren. Das ist halt, glaube ich, wirklich eine Angelegenheit, die vor allem Fans anspricht, die eben sich die 250 Euro gut leisten können. Die denken, die tun mir nicht weh jetzt am Ende des Monats. Da gab es ja auch beispielsweise einen tollen Beitrag vom WDR, der einfach mal durch Gelsenkirchen gestapft ist und verschiedene Personen angesprochen hat. Was haltet ihr denn von der Genossenschaft? Da haben wirklich viele Leute gesagt, ich gebe mein letztes Hemd für den FC Schalke 04, aber ich war auch schon seit Jahren nicht mehr in der Arena, weil ich es mir nicht leisten kann. Und die 250 Euro kann ich mir jetzt recht nicht leisten. Und da vermisse ich dann halt auch schon wieder so ein bisschen diese Rückbesinnung des Vereins auf seine Wurzeln. Weil ja, den Wurzeln ist ja schon lange entwachsen, aber du sprichst ja nicht wirklich den Gelsenkirchener Nachfolger von Asi Erich an, sondern du gehst schon auf gut situierte Leute. Und auch wenn du die anschaust an so einem Spieltag, wenn du auf dem Weg hoch das Berger Feld bist, da kommen relativ wenige Leute noch mit der Burgestra an, also mit der Straßenbahn, sondern da sind eher eben Autokennzeichen aus aller Herren Landkreise unterwegs. Und das merkst du dann halt auch im Stadion. Also ich glaube, der Anteil von nicht gelsen Kirchen und nicht Ruhrportlern liegt vielleicht bei 70, 80 Prozent. Das ist per se eben nicht schlecht, werde ich gesagt, weil der Verein einfach so groß ist und so groß gewachsen ist. Aber die Gemeinschaft und die Genossenschaft. Aber die Gemeinschaft Schalke und die Genossenschaft Schalke gehen da nicht unbedingt einher, weil dieser Grundgedanke, gelsen Kirchen, Fußballverein wird jetzt auch in der Genossenschaft nicht irgendwie groß abgedeckt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch gar nicht das Ziel, sondern das Ziel ist, mit einer pfiffigen Idee so viel Geld wie möglich rauszuholen, um sich ein bisschen Luft zum Verschnaufen zu erkaufen. Wobei ich da aber auch gesagt habe, ich gebe dem Verein gerne ein bisschen Geld, weil ich es kann. Aber die Frage ist eher, möchte ich dem aktuellen Management das Geld geben? Und diese Frage habe ich auch von vielen Personen aus meinem Umfeld, aus dem Schalker Fan-Umfeld gehört. Also ja, Geld geben, damit der Verein weiter erhalten bleibt und dass wir weiter alle zwei Wochen hinkilgern können. Aber will man eben diesen Personen das Geld in die Hand geben? Sieht man da wirklich eine Vision, was mit dem Geld gemacht wird? Weil du hattest es ja gesagt, Eva, das ist alles so ein bisschen schwammig. Also man sagt, man möchte diese Anteile zurückkaufen und dadurch die Tilgungslast mindern. Und wenn es super läuft, dann will man auch in die Infrastruktur investieren. Aber was genau da geplant sein könnte, ist halt so ein bisschen in der Schwebe. Oder wann es geplant sein könnte. Und das ist halt dann auch so ein bisschen Stand heute. Ich meine, die ganze Kampagne läuft jetzt auch schon ein paar Wochen. Es ist so ein bisschen frustrierend, dass man da... Ich meine, 6 Millionen sind viel. Aber dass man da jetzt so ein bisschen... Es ist halt weder Fisch noch Fleisch. Man hat so ein bisschen Geld eingenommen, aber halt auch kein Geld, was jetzt irgendwie kriegsentscheidend oder spielentscheidend sein wird.
Vor allem nicht in der Grand Scheme. Weil natürlich viele dann noch dran denken, mit meinem Geld, da kann man dann den nächsten Top-Schürmer verpflichten oder so, aber das ist ja wirklich dann eher die 800. Stelle, die dann bedacht werden kann.
Wobei auch das ja, also dieses Narrativ wurde ja auch von der Vereinsführung durchaus genährt. Also Tillmann hat immer gesagt, wenn jetzt 50 Millionen, was das Maximum wäre, mit dieser ersten Phase von 190.400 Anteilen. Oder wenn wir die 50 Millionen einnehmen, dann ändert sich die Welt auf Schalke. Dann können wir auch richtig in den Kader investieren. Auch schon bei 20 Millionen könnten wir richtige Topspieler verpflichten. Wo ich mir halt auch denke, das kann ja gut sein. Aber warum pflanzst du das den Leuten so in den Kopf? Also keiner wird jetzt die 6 Millionen sehen und denken, gutes Geld, die werden da sicherlich was draus machen. Alle werden sehen, 6 Millionen, also scheiß auf die 20 Millionen, wir können auch schon für 6 Millionen was mit dem Kader machen. Aber eigentlich ist das ja nicht der Plan, dass man so kurzfristig denkt, sondern diese ganze Genossenschaft ist darauf ausgelegt, dass man auf mittelfristige Sicht und auf langfristige Sicht den Stammverein stärkt, damit er grundsätzlich mehr Kapazitäten monetär hat, um sich nachhaltig zu verstärken oder nachhaltig sportlich aufzustellen. Also es soll keine einmalige Sache sein, wir nehmen 6 Millionen an, die ballern wir sofort im Sommer raus. Aber durch eben solche Aussagen wie von Tillmann und gerade in der heutigen Zeit verkürzt, ein TikTok stellt so da, das zweite schon so und das dritte ist dann halt, ja die 6 Millionen landen im Kader. Das hast du ja auch nicht mehr eingefangen. Machst du es dir halt selbst ein bisschen schwer.
Ja, wir haben enorm überzogen mit der Zeit und ich bedanke mich trotzdem recht herzlich, dass ihr beide dabei wart. Ich würde es aber deshalb an der Stelle jetzt auch tatsächlich hier ein bisschen karten, weil wir könnten da sicherlich noch sehr lange drüber reden, weil ich es auch einfach super interessant finde über also, weil wir natürlich da auch immer über das Thema reden, 50 plus 1 und inwieweit wird es überhaupt in den 36 Profiklubs der DFL gelebt, aber wie nachhaltig sind die einzelnen Modelle mit GmbH und KUK AG und was auch noch alles, KGAA etc. überhaupt, das ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr spannend. Mal sehen, vielleicht müssen wir dann Max einfach nochmal bequatschen, dass er da nochmal ein sehr, sehr ausführliches Trainingsgespräch macht, aber ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz herzlich bei meinen beiden Gästen. Das allererstes bei Jan. Jan, schön, dass du nach fünf Jahren auch ohne Corona mal wieder im Rasenfunk dabei warst.
Es war mir eine sehr große Freude.
Das freut mich auf jeden Fall und dann natürlich auch lieben, lieben Dank an Dominik. Schön, dass du uns etwas zur Schalke sportlich als auch finanziell erklärt hast. Danke, dass du wieder dabei warst.
Danke, immer wieder gerne.
So, und dann, wie versprochen, hört ihr mich jetzt erstmal nicht so schnell wieder, sondern der Marc übernimmt zumindest schon mal die nächste Folge. Da werde ich mich nämlich im DFB-Bokal-Halbfinal-Studel befinden und deshalb nicht hier sitzen. Habt viel Spaß mit der Länderspielpause und dann hören wir uns in zwei Wochen hier wieder. Tschüss.
Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.